- It is like a raw squid.
(Rie laughs)
Is it?
Hi, it's Rie and,
- I'm Tway.
- Yay.
- So it's so exciting to have her today.
She's going to be a new
host of Making It Big.
- I'm kind of nervous for that,
but it's really, really exciting.
- Yeah.
Today we are not making anything big.
- Okay.
- But we are swapping snacks.
- Ooh.
- I picked my favorite Japanese snacks.
- Okay, I'm excited for that.
I have some really good
Vietnamese snacks for you.
Let's bring the first one in.
- Yeah.
1, 2, 3.
- [Tway] Ooh.
- All right, so mine is called JagaRico.
Have you seen this?
- No, I've never seen that.
- Okay. This is my favorite
since when I was high school.
This is actually made
with potato salad, so...
- Potato salad?
- Yeah.
- Whoa.
- So if you...
- I thought you were gonna say
so this is a potato snack
that's made out of potato.
(Rie laughs)
- So if you soak hot water,
this becomes potato salad.
- Whoa. Okay, that's cool.
So this is my snack.
- [Rie] Mhmm.
I don't know what it's called
because I can't read this
but I call it rice rolls.
- Okay.
- And this one is my favorite flavor.
It's an egg yolk flavor.
This was always in the pantry.
I never cared for it
because this doesn't
look appetizing to me.
There's like beans.
- Yeah, look very healthy.
- Yes, it just looks so healthy.
But one day I just needed a quick snack
and I was like: okay fine,
I'll finally give this a try.
And I finished all of it.
- Oh my God.
- In one sitting because it
is just like so addictive.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah.
- Let's swap.
- Here you go.
Looks like a seasoned fry.
- Yeah.
- I like this a lot.
- Yeah?
- It's a nice mouth feel.
- Mm. Mouth feel.
(Rie giggles)
- I definitely could finish
this in like 10 minutes.
I don't think I've had anything similar
snack-wise to this, but maybe
like a stale McDonald's fry?
(Rie laughs)
- Flavor is stale fry.
- Yes.
- But crunchy.
- But crunchy, right.
Please try mine.
- Yes.
- I've never introduced anybody to this.
This has been like my little secret.
- Oh wow.
(playful music)
Mmm.
It melts in your mouth.
- Yes.
- I think it's addictive
because it doesn't have
a very strong flavor.
- I'm so happy you liked it.
- No.
Do we have to decide?
- [Producer] Yes.
- I will keep mine.
- I think I will also keep mine.
- Mmm. It's so difficult to
give up your own favorite snack.
- Right, it's so...
- That was fun, but we
have more snacks to swap.
- Yeah. I'm excited.
Ready?
- Yeah.
- 3, 2, 1.
- [Rie] All right.
- [Tway] Oh, yes.
- You so excited.
- Yes. So this is called Banh Pia,
- [Rie] Uh huh.
- And this is my favorite flavor.
I'm not sure if you've
ever tried durian before.
(record scratches)
- Okay.
(Rie laughs)
- But this is durian flavor.
- Okay.
- With a cured egg yolk inside.
- Okay. I've never had durian itself.
- Okay.
- But I had a durian moon cake before.
- [Tway] Ooh, that's good.
- And it was good.
- I don't know who this is according to,
but I guess it's like the
stinkiest fruit in the world.
But to me, like, it was
always super fragrant.
I really like to snack after the gym,
especially like sweet snacks.
So yeah, after the gym snack.
- [Rie] Okay.
- For the gains.
- Okay, so mine is Toppo.
- I have seen these before.
- [Rie] Yeah, so...
- [Tway] But I've never tried it.
- They say it's just a
reverse engineer of Pocky.
You know, everyone know Pocky, right?
- [Tway] Yeah.
- Pocky is a pretzel stick
covered with chocolate.
But sometimes it get melty,
especially hot outside,
it stick in the package,
but Toppo, very smart.
It's chocolate is inside.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- Okay, here you go.
- Let's do it.
(suspenseful music)
Mmm, it's very creamy.
It's like a lot of flavor
come in a different timing.
Like first I tasted something very creamy
and then like pandan, kind of
refreshing pandan smell came,
and then like aftertaste is like durian.
- Yeah, so everything like kinda unfold.
- I like it.
Yeah.
- All right, I wanna try yours now.
(playful music)
Oh wow.
I didn't expect there to be
that much chocolate in a bite.
I like that it's not too sweet.
- That's like Asian sweets compliment.
- That's a compliment.
(duo giggles)
- A lot of Asian people...
- It's not too sweet.
- When they eat sweet stuff
and that's the best compliment.
- Yeah, not too sweet.
- Not too sweet.
- Since I keep eating
this, I'm gonna keep this.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
(Rie giggles)
- No, literally I just keep eating it.
- Okay, I'm gonna choose this.
- Wow.
- 'Cause I feel like this
is a little bit boring.
3, 2, 1.
(Tway woops)
Full disclosure, this
is not Japanese dessert.
- Okay.
- But Japan has trend every year
and this was became very popular.
It's called Nata de Coco.
- Oh, okay.
- It's Filipino dessert.
- Yeah.
- Have you had this kind of experience
when you had something so delicious,
but you have no idea what it is
and you are kind of like in a outer space
and like, you kind of...
- Whoa.
You had an out-of-body experience.
- Yeah.
- Maybe I'm about to have that right now.
(Rie laughs)
I'm pretty sure you've had
this before, but this is...
- No.
- Okay well, this is just soy milk.
- Okay.
- So this soy milk is my childhood.
I would have this at school all the time.
This is what they would serve at school.
Whenever I hear people say
that they don't like soy milk,
I automatically know that they
have not had Asian soy milk
because America soy milk
versus Asian soy milk
is completely different,
but this is the way to go.
- All right, let's swap.
- Oh, it's Greek yogurt.
(violin music)
I always love the texture
of coco de - what is it?
- Nata de coco.
- It is harder than jelly.
- The jelly.
- It is like a raw squid?
Is it?
- If you could bite into a jellyfish.
- [Rie] Yes.
- That would be the
texture of a jellyfish.
I like the pandan though.
- Yeah.
- This is my life changing dessert.
(Tway laughs)
- I did not have an
out of body experience.
- Now I'm gonna try yours.
- Okay.
That straw is cool. It's a paper straw.
Thoughts?
(Rie laughs)
- This is the soy milk I'm familiar with.
- Right?
It's so good.
- It's more creamy and
it's a little bit sweeter.
- Mhmm.
Okay, I have to admit something.
- Mhmm?
- I don't like the yogurt.
(Rie laughs)
I'm gonna have to swap and
have the soy milk over here.
- Fine, I'm gonna swap
mine. I love nata de coco.
All right.
- Last one.
Yes.
I am so excited for you to try.
So this is Beard Papa's.
- [Tway] Okay.
- Cream puff.
- Interesting name.
- Yes. The choux is very crisp
because they stuff cream when you order.
And I like tea, so whenever I have time,
like I wanna make myself a cup of tea
and like have something sweet.
- Yeah.
- And this is perfect.
And it's like perfect size.
- Yeah.
So here is a moon cake.
- Oh.
- And this is my favorite
filling in moon cake
is the mixed nuts.
This time there's two yolks in here.
This is very common in Vietnam
around this time of the year.
It's the mid autumn festival.
We celebrate that.
And this is my favorite moon cake.
There's a lot of different
types of moon cakes
and different types of filling.
But this is my favorite, like all time.
- Let's swap.
- There you go.
- Mmm, that's ginger?
- Mhmm, it has everything.
- Mmm. Reminds me of my like childhood
when I had a snack at
my grandparents' house.
- Yeah.
- It's a little bit savory.
- Yeah, that's what I love about it.
- Yeah.
- And that's why I love
about the egg yolk,
the outer layer's like sweet,
that makes nuts just a little bit sweet.
It's not too much.
It's a interesting, very
interesting flavors and textures.
- Right.
- I really want to dig into this.
- [Rie] Yeah.
- Should I just like?
- You can just...
- Or should I just bite into it?
- You just bite into it.
- This is so good.
- Yay.
- There's also like little
specs of like vanilla there too.
- Yes, vanilla beans.
- Yeah. I really love the outside.
- It's still...
- It's not too soggy.
- Yeah, yeah. Can I have it too?
(duo laughs)
- Yes. Yes.
Oh my God.
This is...
- It's just so perfect.
- Yeah.
- Not too sweet.
- So you can eat like the full thing
without feeling like I
just ate the full thing.
- Mmmm.
Reminds me of my childhood.
I'm gonna keep mine.
- I'm actually gonna swap to hers.
This is really good.
- eah.
Thank you so much for watching
and thank you so much
for joining me today.
- Yeah, well thank you for having me
and make sure to tune
in on the next season
of Making It Big.
- Maybe she's gonna make
cream puff, giant puff.
- Ooh.
(Rie giggles)
(upbeat music)